okay because we were off on Monday and
Tuesday we have the distinct pleasure of
jumping into hatred mail on the first
new show this week here's a quick
reminder about what hatred mail is
because we cling to our guns and our God
but somehow totally cool with a
billionaire who wants to assault our
wife Patriot mail written by Patriots
who hate David Pakman because America
and because freedom
all right this week's hatred mail is a
particular type of odd I don't know that
it needs much more of an introduction
let's take a listen to it together
Trump hates fake news and it's only a
matter of time before he shuts you and
other leftist fake news down I hope you
have fun being deported back to
Argentina you live tarde Cox are so
pathetic you attack Trump and other
Patriots but won't ever talk about
Islamic terrorism and even block anyone
who mentions it leftists hate free
speech and lose Sharia law if you love
Sharia law then moved to Isis where they
have secular Sharia law I met you and
your new boyfriend mutually pleasured to
Isis propaganda videos and leftist fake
news what happened to your ex boyfriend
Louise did he leave you for another Jew
Chuck you low info snowflakes are
self-destructing and people are now
realizing that how stupid you are I
think that actually all this sounds like
the rantings of a madman yeah and it is
but there's one element here that maybe
has a grain of truth which is there is
definitely a renewed movement to shut
down news that the administration
doesn't like and that is something
really really scary that we've actually
been covering I think that it's merely
by chance that the hatred gets stumbled
upon something that does reflect the
attitude of the administration oh sure
and of course this hay tree of mail had
some undertones of anti-semitism and
homophobia
right but why would Isis welcome us then
yeah there are the first people against
that sort of stuff and what does it mean
that Isis is secular Sharia law that's a
really odd thing I don't know where this
person is coming up with this time we do
talk about is almost terrorism all the
time that's the other thing in fact
we're criticized as Islamophobic because
we talk about Islamic terror sometimes
so I guess the key there you can't be on
either side of that without taking some
heat and if you're in the middle then
you I guess you take heat from both but
the good news is you can turn hatred
mail into something positive we have a
coupon code which is hey tree at 40 H
atri ot 40 it'll save you 40% off of a
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership you can check that out